scams cost Americans roughly fifty
billion dollars every year the Better
Business Bureau estimates they effect
one in four homes the most frequently
reported scams are delivered by your
phone but more than half of the victims
say they were contacted online through
websites email social media and more
Anna Werner has been investigating a
scam on the world's most popular social
network she's at Facebook headquarters
ATS in Menlo Park California and a good
morning good morning well you might
think that you wouldn't fall for a scam
on Facebook but experts say more and
more people including Millennials are
becoming the victims here and this scam
raises a question what happens when a
person you think is a Facebook friend
turns out to be someone else I wouldn't
wish this on an enemy that's Shelley
Drummond's reaction to what happened to
her on Facebook it started when she
found the profile for a friend from
years back named Deborah Boyd I was on
messenger and my friend's name came up
soon her friend Boyd was telling her
about a so-called government grant she'd
gotten through an agent on Facebook
sure enough the agent then told Drummond
she could get financial assistance from
the government all she had to do was
provide some personal information then
send $1,500 in fees to get up to
$100,000 in grant money the person that
I was corresponding with that I thought
was my friend had vouched for this
foundation and I believed her so
Drummond wired the $1,500 to Florida
then waited for the delivery driver like
the one shown on Facebook to deliver her
one hundred thousand dollars in cash but
they never came and when she tracked
down her friend Boyd by phone I said
Shelley it wasn't me you got scared
turns out Boyd's Facebook account had
been hacked by scammers who locked her
out then quickly reached out to try to
con her family and friends who she then
had to warn please do not send them
anything and delete yourself off that
page because it's not me Emma Fletcher
is with the Better Business Bureau there
basically capturing that trust you have
in this person and using it for their
own gain so we wondered where the
scammer is still active to find out we
set up our own fake account on Facebook
and contacted voids impostor sure enough
she claimed she got a fifty thousand
dollar grant and said we could get one
too
it wasn't alone and we wouldn't have to
pay it back she's not wasting any time
something we showed Fletcher as the
conversation progressed is that typical
of what you see happening well once you
show an interest you know they're going
to go in for the kill and it wasn't just
the fake debra boyd account we found
what appears to be a network of fake
facebook profiles offering grants from
50,000 to 1 million dollars all while
assuring us it wasn't a scam swear to
god one said but those photos of the
agents a quick search using Google
images turned up the truth the photos
are real but those people don't offer
grants one is a real estate agent from
Vermont the other a professor at MIT so
if those aren't the real people who's
really running those Facebook accounts
what this website is is a IP tracker
mean computer expert gary malevsky he
set up a way to track the scammers
location he built this page that looks
like a money transfer companies website
but really finds a computer's unique
identifier and location so when they
click the link thinking they're going to
a money popular money transfer website
they're allowing us to track them
we got the scammers to click on it and
lo and behold there we are now we're in
Lagos Nigeria that's right those
scammers are in Nigeria Russians use
malware the Chinese use malware the
Nigerians they use social engineering
and they use social media but if we were
able to track them what about Facebook
the company told us it has a dedicated
team helping to detect and block these
kinds of scams and has developed several
techniques to stop the abuse but Boyd
told us Facebook still hasn't solved her
problems and the scammers still have a
fake
profile up with her name these people
should not still be contacting my
friends and family no way should they be
this is what six months later nine
months later come on well after we
reached out to Facebook and provided
them with the URLs for those scam
accounts it appears they did block those
accounts but Deborah Boyd tells us she's
never been able to get back into her old
account which has a lot of family photos
and memories she'd like to have back by
the way the two people we showed whose
photos were used for the scam on
Facebook one declined to comment but the
other told us she was shocked by what
she saw she had no idea that her own
photo had been taken off her own website
and used by fraudsters for a scam
Nora what a story mana Warner thank you
so much